this is a story of what the computer
repairman saw and of questions it asks
around secrecy and a sitting president
any kind of sarcastically said Biden
like kind of expecting me to know who he
was John Paul mckiser was handed a
laptop for repair by Hunter Biden son of
Joe in the months before the 2020
election
John Paul who's visually impaired showed
us some of the content he kept
the addiction struggles of the
president's son are well documented but
it's not images of drug taking or
self-made pornography that's raising
questions as much as the email traffic
uh the announcement of my guys upcoming
travels now now my guy hunter refers to
his father as my guy award the chairman
or the big guy emails appear to suggest
that Biden Jr was used for access to
Biden senior when he was vice president
and his son was on the board of a
Ukrainian Energy company why they lie to
the American people because he was fully
aware of his son's business dealings he
was a tool of those dealings
it's a computer repair shop that two
years ago was a starting point for a
story that had the look of a
pre-election scandal
it was reported by the New York Post but
the tale that emerged from Wilmington
Delaware hometown of the bidens didn't
travel as far as it might have
John Paul McIver handed the laptop to
the FBI it won Facebook and Twitter of
the potential for Russian disinformation
ahead of the election the tech companies
then restricted the laptop story on
their platforms Joe Biden's Republican
opponents call it election suppression
the laptop and its contents had already
triggered their plans for an
investigation this evidence raises
troubling questions about whether
President Biden is a national security
risk
and about whether he is compromised by
Foreign governments
the story of the laptop that landed here
comes with quotes from the President Joe
Biden was a candidate when it first came
to light before the last election he
dismissed that then as disinformation a
Russian plant he's also said that he's
never had discussions with his son about
any of his overseas business dealings
it's the story that stalks the Biden
still Republicans now have a majority in
the House of Representatives that opens
the door to an investigation once closed
they saw Injustice at a would-be scandal
undersold now this the opportunity to
sell it once more James Matthews Sky
News in Wilmington Delaware